Depending on the pathway analysis approach
that you use to analyze your data, that can
have a dramatic impact on the type of insights
that you're able to derive from your results.
Let's look at how these different analysis
approaches differ from one another.
The first and most common approach is what's
called over-representation analysis.
It's most commonly referred to as enrichment
analysis.
This is a very simple but powerful technique
that leverages simple statistics to identify
pathways that may be significant given your
data.
The other benefit to this particular approach
is that it doesn't require very much input
data.
You can submit a short list of genes that
you're interested in and you'll get a list
of pathways that are enriched for that set
of genes.
The downside to this method is that it makes
an assumption on the background of those genes.
Because you only submitting a short list of
genes, it has to make an assumption of what
is the denominator.
For example, if you have a hundred significant
genes the system might not know what was the
total number of genes that has been analyzed.
In other word, is it hundred significant genes
out of ten thousand, twenty thousand or is
it fifty thousand.
So it makes some assumptions on that.
The other downside to this method is that
you end up throwing away about 90% of your
data.
For example, if you've done an expression
experiment where you have observations for
20,000 genes, usually there's only about a
thousand or 2,000 that you're interested in,
out of that entire set.
That is a major disadvantage because you spend
a lot of time and money in getting those measurements.
The biggest limitation of this method is that
it assumes that all of the genes in the pathway
are independent.
It completely ignores the interactions among
genes within the pathway.
This can lead to a lot of false positives
A slight improvement on enrichment analysis
approach is what's called functional class
scoring.
You may have encountered gene set enrichment
analysis or GSEA which was pioneered by the
Broad Institute.
In this particular model, it is more accurate
than the simple enrichment model because in
this method we're going to use the entire
list of genes that were measured.
In the case of gene set enrichment analysis
we will also supply the p-values and supply
them a ranked order.
Depending on the type of functional class
scoring method, you may provide some weighted
scoring based on those p-value.
But, because this is still based on an enrichment
model, it is still going to ignore the interactions
among the genes on the pathway.
It is still a count-based model and as a result
this method can lead to a lot of false positives.
In the mid 2000, a completely different type
of approach was proposed.
Its goal was to mimic how we think about pathways
from a biological perspective.
In this case we're trying to identify how
perturbed a pathway is given a particular
input.
We can do that by leveraging the topology
of the pathway.
In this particular method, we're going to
consider each gene’s role, their position,
the magnitude of change between our two phenotypes,
and the interactions among other genes in
that particular system.
One of the advantage about this particular
model is that it's able to predict what's
going to occur in that system given the observations
from the data.
However, there are also some downsides to
this method.
First, it requires more data in this particular
model.
We need to have measurements for all of the
genes between the two phenotypes, their measured
fold change, and their p-value.
When this method was proposed, that was a
very difficult and expensive task.
But with advents and improvements in transcriptomics
and proteomics technology, and bioinformatics,
it is a much easier to accomplish.
This method does take slightly longer than
the enrichment models.
The enrichment models can be calculated in
the matter of seconds or less, but the topology-based
model is very computationally intensive and
takes anywhere from five to ten minutes to
calculate.